169 000 pounds per person to send people
to Rwanda if they shouldn't be in the UK
is that value for money
enormously expensive and if
if you followed that course through to
the whole Asylum system it would cost
four times more
than we're paying at the moment so it's
not good value for money okay so what
would you do differently well to get the
uh to get the numbers down uh there's a
number of things which are out with the
passing of these pieces of declaratory
legislation you've got a process that
claims clicker who's become much slower
to find out who should be here and who
shouldn't and then act accordingly
uh you have to crack down more
vigorously on the gangs who are
organizing this trade you've got to get
returns agreements in place because we
haven't got enough of those in place at
the moment and you have to cooperate
with other countries and trying to stop
this trade it's a tough problem to crack
but these are the hard measures that you
have to do if we end up paying 170
000 pounds for every person this is
going to cost the country a huge amount
of money but
if it deters 37 of people from crossing
the channel these are all statistics
we're actually talking about individual
people lives of course but if 37 of
people don't come as a result of this
deterrent then it's value for money well
let's see what happens there uh so far
it certainly doesn't seem to have had
that kind of impact
um
talk to me if you would in a little bit
more detail about the financial support
for people seeking Asylum we're hearing
that that should be increased at present
it's 70 percent of of Universal Credit
or sorry that's that's what Caroline
Nokes and her committee would like it to
be
um we've been running a poll this
morning from our viewers about how they
feel about supporting um illegal
migrants depends on which side of the
defense you are whether illegal or not
and they would not support doing that
yeah we don't have proposals to change
this at the moment this is our system
we're already spending uh 3.8 billion
pounds a year on uh I believe and it's
costing a huge amount of money already
we're spending six or seven million
pounds a day to keep people go to work
and hotels no you can only go to work if
you are legally entitled to be here how
can you live on 45 pounds a week look
it's really really tough for people and
what you've got to do is speed up the
process accessing of the claim and if
you're then judged to be legally
entitled to be in the country then the
situation is you can work but we don't
have a proposal to let people work
before the status is clarified 45 pounds
a week how do people it's really really
tough but this is an expensive system
and I'm afraid I can't sit here at the
moment and say that we are committed to
spending more than that on it Chancellor
is uh meeting uh Banks to tell them that
they need to pass on interest rate hikes
to Savers they're not doing that quick
enough what's Labor's view well they
should
um for two reasons first of all people
can see their mortgage rates going up
and people are being hit with increases
of four or five hundred pounds a month
when they get a renewable sure
um and at the same time as those
mortgage rates are going up your savings
rate available in a an instant access
account what people would regard as a
normal savings account can be as low as
one percent despite interest rates going
up 13 times over the past two years so
uh banks have got to do more to pass
those on but it's also an
anti-inflationary measure because
how would you make them do that because
they're always the bogeyman aren't they
sure but the regulator's got to put more
pressure on them uh to do this we
announced our package for on mortgage
relief last week we said the regulator
really had to make that happen the
regulator's got to put more pressure on
the banks to pass what would that look
like
well they you know they can tell them to
do it
um you know they can they can make them
do it perhaps in the extreme uh but the
reg the regulator regulates them what
would labor like to see happen I mean
you'd like to see these shadow Chiefs
actually treasury what if you were in
charge what would you be saying to the
banks you call them and you'd say guys
come on you need to do this absolutely
absolutely what stick would you use
these rates have got to be uh passed on
you'd see if the regular can force them
to do it it's quite difficult to force
you know Banks to do a particular thing
but anyone can see the disparity between
getting hit with a six percent rate on
your mortgage and been offered one
percent on your savings yeah but what
what I I press you again on what can
actually be done when the banks needed
the support of the British government
came cap in hand they were in a lot of
trouble they were given billions of
pounds well
you know that going back to that that
was really
about bailing out the British people as
well from a bank collapse and if we
hadn't done that the cash machines would
have stopped working you'd have had
social chaos uh so that was a measure to
protect the public from a bank collapse
as well right now
we want to see the banks responding to
higher interest rates in two ways one
shows some understanding to your
borrowers and we talked about that with
mortgage rates and secondly make sure
that your Savers benefit from this
because that's partly an
anti-inflationary measure to the whole
point of raising interest rates is
supposed to be that people do different
things with their money and one of those
should be to save more and if you
increase the rates you're offering for
Savers that should help with that
the governor of the bank of England
enjoy your full support
yes uh and so his right to increase
interest rates in the way that he has
we've given the bank of England a job
and it's really important that they be
allowed to do that job and I see this to
be around politics at the moment of uh
blame the bank and we gave the bank when
I say we I mean the labor party gave the
bank of England Independence when we
were in government a long time ago and
when we did that we gave them the job of
controlling inflation and setting
interest rates
and I think it would be a real mistake
for politicians to start second guessing
those decisions now undermining the
independence of the bank because if you
remember that disastrous Tory mini
budget last September part of the
backdrop to that was the Tory government
undermining The Economic Institutions
the bank the treasury the obr and That
Shook International confidence in the
UK's Financial
and if it goes up even higher which is
somewhere protection it's got another
one and a quarter percent uh in uh rate
Rises before it starts to come back down
again Andrew Bailey would still have
your full support
it's not about seeing any interest rate
is good it's about saying they've got a
job they should be allowed to do that
job you're doing a good job they've got
their legislative job they should be
allowed to get on with that and
politicians I have confidence in the
bank I'm not about to second-guess them
uh because I think that would be worse
for the UK's Financial stability and
would send a really bad signal out to
International markets and to others that
the UK government or the UK opposition
didn't have confidence in its Central
Bank that's not a signal I'm about here
comes the just stop oil question uh your
party takes money from Dale Vince
who also supports um just stop oil
Trevor Nielsen who co-founded the
climate emergency fund has said that
just stop oil have gone too far the
disruption is just for the sake of
disruption
um do you agree with that I'm not in
favor of any disruption that stops
people getting to work going about their
business
getting to medical appointments and so
on some of these protests have been
enormously disruptive I'm also not in
favor of anybody disrupting sporting
events we saw it with a snooker we've
had threats of it with other events uh I
think these protesters should stop doing
this and let people go to the show
actually in just a short time he who
Support also supports the labor party
supports just stop oil financially and
he went on a march with them well you've
got to ask him about it but I'm asking
you because he's not sat in front of him
told you what I said but should he be
doing that should he be taking money
from somebody who does this sort of
thing if somebody gives us money uh I
don't legislate for everything else that
they want to do with their money but
I've got a very clear view on these
protests how destructive they are and
the right for people to go about their
daily business and what would you say to
Dale Vince about going on future
demonstration he's a free citizen I
would hope he wouldn't go on anything
that would disrupt the sport and event
he has already well I would hope as I
say no one would take part in disruption
of sport and events or stopping people
going about their daily business I want
to see people get to work I want to see
them get to our medical appointments I
want I don't want the motorway blocked
anything like that there's ways to make
a point these are not the best ways just
stop it Mr Vince it's not a good idea
it's not about Mr Vince it's about
letting people
go about their daily business that's
what I want to see I think I've been
quite clear you haven't that's I keep
pressing you on it should he continue to
do this it's a matter for him who
refunds but these protests are doing
process March he went I mean protest
marks is one thing but stopping people
going about their business but don't do
it is what you're saying I don't want
any of them to do it there you go you
were clear eventually Pat McFadden's
always a pleasure thank you very much